I'm going to teach you how to write a
viral ad in just 60 seconds. Watch this.
We're going to use a copywriting formula
called P A S. It stands for problem,
agitation, solution. Here's how this
works. You need to state a problem that
your target audience has. Something like
this. Do you sit in a chair for more
than 4 hours per day? Okay? We've stated
a problem that they have. And then the
next is you want to agitate that
problem. You want to make it way bigger
than they were just feeling, okay? Then
you're going to say something like this.
You're destroying your spine and
increasing your chances of surgery by
43%.
Now this relatively small problem of
sitting in a chair for more than 4 hours
a day just became a huge problem because
you agitated the pain. And then you plug
your solution. Check out our all-in-one
standing desks for $9.99. Whatever it
is. That is a way to get them to go from
a problem, oh I see that I do this, to
agitate, whoa I didn't know it was that
bad, to solution, let me check this out
if it solves my problem. Bam.